both mitosis and meiosis are forms of
cell division that produce daughter
cells containing genetic information
from the parent cell
part a describe two events that are
common to both mitosis and meiosis that
ensure the resulting daughter cells
inherit the appropriate number of
chromosomes all right so really we just
want to well what are two commonalities
between the two well i can think of a
bunch of them
you could start off saying well dna
replicates before going into either of
them
so
dna
replicates
before either
before
either
you could say well the chromatin
condenses into chromosome
in both of them
chromatochromatin
chromatin
condenses
into
into chromosomes
you could talk about chromosomes
for
getting aligned near the center of the
cell
attaching to
to
fibers you could talk about
you could we could talk about
cytokinesis splitting the cells so cyto
kinesis involved
involved
in creation of separate cells
creation
of separate
separate
cells
in general
the
your your meiosis one has a lot of
analogs with mitosis in general you
could you could keep looking keep
digging deeper and listening more and
more they just want me to describe two
events i've already described three
well i'll i'll leave it at that for now
in general before you take the ap test
mitosis and meiosis are good things to
know in detail
because you might see questions like
this on the free answer section or
they're likely to show up in the
multiple choice section as well but i
think this is sufficient for part a
we've described at least two events that
are common to both mitosis and meiosis
if you have extra time you might try to
list more
and then part b the genetic composition
of daughter cells produced by mitosis
differ differs from that of the daughter
cells produced by meiosis describe two
features of the cell division process
that lead to these differences
well maybe the most obvious one the
biggest difference between them is
mitosis
mitosis involves one division
involves
one
division
meiosis involves two
meiosis
involves
involves not innolves
involves two
this
leads
to
two
daughter
cells
from
mitosis
and
four
daughter
cells
from
meiosis
that looks that's a that's a a pretty
big difference between the two
another big difference and this is
related to this
because
meiosis has an extra division
has
extra
division
but
dna
replicates
once like in
once
like
in
mitosis
the daughter cells from meiosis have
half the number of chromosomes there
they have a haploid number of
chromosomes
the
daughter
cells
in
meiosis
have
a haploid
number of chromosomes
number
of
chromosomes
so and we say mitosis daughters have
diploid
daughters
have diploid number
and these are probably the two strongest
differences but you could talk about
other things you could talk about
crossing over occurring in meiosis but
not in mitosis you could talk about the
separation and independent assortment of
homologous chromosomes that you have
homologous each each member of a
homologous pair that you have in meiosis
that you don't have in mitosis so
there's a bunch of things you could talk
about and you can go into arbitrary
detail it's nice that they only have to
list two in each of these in each of
these parts of question four